Now there are other situations we can run into, too. For example, let's say we
have 2 robots that are shooting at each other through a wall. Maybe they're not
the brightest robots in the world. Or, maybe they are. Let's take a closer look
at this situation. We have a few different bounding boxes to consider. We have
this wall made up of a few bounding boxes, and we also have the bounding box of
the rocket. So let's say we have this rocket here, and in one time step of the
physics engine, it is on this side of the wall. But on the next time step of
the physics engine, it is on this side of the wall. Now, everything in our
physics engine happens at discrete steps, so there's no point at which this
bounding box and this bounding box intersect. So then, which bounding box
should we use? Do we want to end up using this bounding box, right here? Or
maybe we should calculate some halfway point between the 2, right here, and use
that bounding box. Or maybe we want to use the entire swept area, swept out
between the 2 time steps and use that instead. Now the box I've drawn is a
little bit bigger than the path that would be swept out between these 2 time
steps. Which of these do you think that we should use to properly calculate
collisions? Check which ever single one you think is appropriate.